the Feaster from afar the unspeakable
one him who is not to be named the
yellow king after stumbling queerly upon
the hellish and forbidden book of
Horrors the to learn among other hideous
things which no sane mortal should know
that this talisman is indeed the
nameless yellow sign and it down from
the accursed cult of Hester today we are
once again exploring a Cthulhu Mythos
and another one of its obscure deities
ha stories of entities that goes by many
names and contrary to popular belief he
was not actually created by Lovecraft he
first appeared in heishi the Shepard a
short story by Ambrose Bierce in 1893 in
the story house there was a God of
shepherds and he appeared to be quite
harmless a depiction that differs
greatly from the work that followed law
frost himself early mentioned Hester's
name once in his short story the
Whisperer in the darkness the name is
sandwiched in between various other
deities and places which created some
confusion and plenty of debate as to
whether Lovecraft intended Hester to be
a deity himself or rather another the
location in his mythos has the would
however later be recognized as a great
old one
the child of yokes are Thoth and the
half-brother of the great dream of
Cthulhu the allure King resides in
Carcosa an ancient city created by
Ambrose Bierce we don't know much about
Carcosa
other than it was once ancient and
mysterious but after its destruction it
resembles nothing more than the ruins of
a once great place the best description
we have of Hester's home comes from
Robert W Chambers and Lynn Carter in the
stories and inhabitant of Carcosa and a
litany - Hester Carcosa is described as
having black stars hanging in a bright
sky large black domes and monolithic
towers scattered everywhere its main
source of light comes from twin suns
that eventually sink into the lake of
Hali bring in darkness has - like many
of the creatures and deities at
appearing at Cthulhu Mythos
does not have one clearly defined form
the most common unrecognizable of these
forms is a large entity dressed in
yellow with tentacles reminiscent of his
half-brother Cthulhu but not octopus and
squid like among his many forms has -
also has avatars that he can transfer
his consciousness into these avatars are
used to communicate and influence
humankind the most common of these
avatars is of course the king in yellow
a hunched figure dressed in a tattered
yellow gown
concealed in his face of a mosque that
is devoid of any emotion what lies
beneath this mosque is something that we
can only speculate about what
as it conceals we can only hope that we
never encounter the Feaster from afar by
Joseph Paine describes one of these
incarnations as a black shriveled
monstrosity with tentacles tipped of
razor-sharp talons that can pierce a
victim's skull and siphon out the brain
definitely not the friendly patron of
Sheppard's that Ambrose once introduced
in US on occasion the king in yellow has
been known to appear in our dimension
where he attempts to turn all of those
he comes across to his cores much like
his brothers efforts to grow the cult of
Cthulhu the main tool used by Hastur to
grow his cult is the yellow sign anyone
who gazes upon it falls instantly under
the influence of the yellow King those
who lucky enough to escape the yellow
sign are then visited by hosta himself
ensuring that they remain under his
control we may not be able to comprehend
Hester and his motives but we know that
he has a deep hatred for his brother
Cthulhu with Hastur Masonic cult
following
many of theorize that he is indeed
building an army to finally destroy
Cthulhu when he rises from earlier for
anyone who's watched the first season of
True detective you may record that a
nickname given to the murderer being
pursued was the yellow King there were
also several references made to the work
of Robert W Chambers in the form of a
journal that mentions black fallen stars
and a location known as Carcosa Hester
is definitely one of the most
interesting characters to appear in a
Cthulhu Mythos that wasn't created by
Lovecraft and the hatred between
hysteric a thorough definitely creates
an interesting dynamic so what do you
think has earned his cult have planned
if you did happen to watch true
detective and you didn't get any of the
references does know about them they'll
make the show seem any more scary or
eerie let me know in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
in fiction explained
you